สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคาร
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
13 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  23 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
15 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 2566
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 21:00
น
21  21 นกี่
นาที
21  31 นค่ะ
2131 น 21 น
ครูฟ้า 21:30 นแต่เรา 2 คนอยู่บ้านเหรอ
คะทำไมคะครูหญิงก็ 21:30 นก็อยู่ที่บ้าน
ไงก็โอเคครูฟ้าไม่ได้นะคะวันนี้เนี่ยวัน
นี้ 21:30 นเนี่ยเราอยู่บ้านไม่
ได้ทำไมอ่ะครูหญิงทำไมเราอยู่บ้านไม่ได้
อ่ะก็วันนี้วันที่ 14 กุมภาพันธ์เป็นวัน
วาเลนไท
ต้องมี S ด้วยอ่าน
มา
วาเลนไทนใช่วันนี้เป็นวันวาเลนไทน์ไง
21:00 นเนี่ยครูหญิงครูฟ้าทำไมอยู่บ้าน
ไม่ได้สิคะเราต้องไปเดทคงเพราะว่าเราไม่
มีแฟนมั้งูฟ้าไม่เป็นไรไงคะเราไม่มีแฟน
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็อาจจะไปเดทกับผู้ชาย
ได้อ้าหรอโอผู้หญิงดีมากเลยค่ะครูฟ้าจะไป
เดทที่ไหนดีล่ะจริงๆครูฟ้าไม่มีแฟนแต่
ก็ก็ไปเดทได้อยู่นะคะค่ะก็ไปเดทก็คือไป
เดทกับอ่ะสมมติไปเดทกับมิสเต a แล้วก็อาจ
จะอืมไม่โอเคไม่ชอบก็เปลี่ยนไปเดทกับไป
เดทกับมิสเต B มิสเตอร C จนกว่าเราจะชอบ
นี้ไม่ได้เป็นแฟนก็ไปเดทกันอ่าแต่ครูหญิง
รู้ค่ะว่าทำไมวันที่ 14 กุมภาพันธ์ตอน
21:00 นเนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าถึงอยู่
บ้านโดยเฉพาะครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้ไปเดทกับ
ผู้ชายที่ไหนแล้วก็ไม่มีแฟนด้วยแฟนก็ไม่
มีรู้ได้ยังไงคะครูหญิงทำไมครูหญิงรู้สิ
คะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกินใช่มยชอบกินเวลา
ที่เราไปเดทเนี่ยเดทครั้งแรกเนี่ยนะคะ
First เทเนี่ยนะคะ First เทเนี่ยเดท
ครั้งแรกเนี่ยผู้หญิงคิดว่า
99% เราต้องไปกินอาหารอหาร้านอาหารแล้ว
ก็ไปกินข้าวด้วยกันอใช่มยเอ้าก็ถูกแล้ว
ครูหญิงเราก็ต้องกินสิคะเพราะว่าเราหิว
ถูกต้องค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องไปกินอาหารที่
ไม่โอเคในการเดทครั้งแรกแน่ๆเลยผู้ชายก็
เห็นแล้วก็หู
ไม่ใช่ครูฟ้ากินเยอะนะครูหญิงคิดว่าตอน
นี้ 20  0  2  3 เดทครั้งแรกแล้วเรากิน
อาหารเยอะๆผู้ชายอาจจะโอเคหรือเปล่าไม่
รู้
นะก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันเนาะเอ่าครูหญิงถ้า
ครูหญิงไปเดดครั้งแรกแล้วผู้ชายเอ่อผู้
ชายกินอาหารเยอะๆมันก็ปกตินี่หว่าเนาะ
แล้วทำไมผู้หญิงกินอาหารเยอะๆไม่ปกติไม่
โอเคล่ะคูณฟ้าโชว์ทุกคนให้ให้บอกครูฟ้า
บอกให้หมดนะคะว่าครูฟ้ากินอาหารเยอะนะคะู
ฟ้าจะกินอะไรหรือไปไหนกับไปใช่นั่นแหละ
แต่ครูหญิงคิดว่าไม่ใช่ที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกิน
อาหารเยอะแล้วผู้ชายไม่ชอบแล้วเป็นเพราะ
อะไรอ่ะเป็นเพราะว่าครูฟ้าต้องสั่งอาหาร
ที่เป็นเมนูพวกนี้แน่ๆเลยที่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไปอ่านมาใน www.
Google  google.com เนี่ยบอกว่าไม่ได้เม
เมนูอาหารพวกนี้เนี่ยเราห้ามสั่งในการเดท
ครั้งแรกทำไมล่ะทำไมเราถึงห้ามสั่งคะเรา
ก็ต้องไปดูก่อนว่าแต่ละเมนูเนี่ยทำไมถึง
ห้ามสั่งแต่ส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยมันกินไม่สวย
เนี่ยแหละค่ะกินไม่สวยชาบบุฟเฟ่ต์ไม่มี
ไม่
มีไม่มีอยู่ในนี้นะคะไม่มีดีมากดีมากอ่ะ
อย่างแรกเลยอาหารที่เป็นพวกเมนูเส้นใช่
มั้ยเนี่ยเป็นเส้นแบบเนี้ยไม่ว่าจะเป็น
อะไรเนี่ยมีผัดนะคะอืสปาเกตตี้ก็เป็นเส้น
ใช่มั้ยคะหรือว่าของไทยเราก็คือ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็เป็นเส้นหิวล่ะ
สิไม่
ได้เมนูที่เป็นเส้นเนี่ยครูฟ้าสั่งสั่ง
หรือเปล่าตอนครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปเดทครั้งแรกเ้า
แน่นอนูว่าชอบกินเส้นนะคะสปาเกตตี้อะไร
อย่างเงี้ยเออโหสปาเกตตี้แล้วถ้าสั่งซอส
เนี้ยเนี่ยซอสอะไรเนี่ยซอสมะเขือเทศเนี่ย
เทศ
โแล้วใส่ชุดชุดสีขาวใส่เสื้อสี
ชมพูไปกินข้าวแล้วผู้ชายก็เห็นโอ้ฟ้าอายุ
27 ปีหรือว่าอายุ 27 วัน
เอคือยังไงคะูหญิงผู้ชายพูดแบบนี้ได้ยัง
ไงผู้ชายคิดคิดอ่าอันนี้ครูฟ้านั่งอยู่
ที่นี่ใช่มยกินสปาเกตตี้ผู้ชายเนี่ยก็คิด
โหเอ้าก็เวลาครูฟ้ากินสปาเกตตี้แล้วซอส
มันก็กระเด็นกระเด็นกระเด็นกระเด็น
กระเด็นกระเด็นโดนเสื้อของเราไงเลอะที่
ปาก
อีกเวลากินอ่ะสปาเกตตี้เนี่ยอาจจะไม่มีนะ
คะแต่ถ้าเรากินก๋วยเตี๋ยวหรือว่ากินพวก
หมี่ผัดแบบอาหารจีนอย่างเงี้ยแล้วใช้
ตะเกียบเนี่ยโอใช้ตะเกียบแบบเนี้ย
สปาเกตตี้เนี่ยเรายังใช้ซ่อมใช่ไหมใช้
ส้อมใช้ช้อนอ่าแต่ว่าก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยส่วน
ใหญ่เราจะใช้ตะเกียบแล้วครูฟ้าก็เอา
ตะเกียบเนี่ยคีบเส้นแล้วก็ซูดอย่างเงี้ย
นะคะซอสเอ่อซุปอาจะกระเด็นใส่ผู้ชายก็ได้
เอ้ามันไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียนเดทครั้งแรก
เนี่ยมันไม่โอเคแต่ถ้าครูฟ้าไปเดทกับ
มิสเตอร์ a อืแล้วมันมีเดทครั้งที่
2 ครูฟ้าอยากจะสั่งก๋วยเตี๋ยวสปาเกตตี้
คุหิรู้สึกว่าทุกเมนูโอเคเลยแต่เดทครั้ง
แรกเนี่ยเราไม่เคยเจอกันไงมันก็ต้องแบบ
ให้เราดูดีอะไรที่ไม่ดีสำหรับเราอ่ะอย่า
ทำมันก็ต้องดูดีนิดนึงใช่มั้ยคะเดใช่ใช่
ค่ะเพราะมันคือครั้งแรกไงคะนักเรียนเออ
มันไม่รู้จักกันเลยแชทอย่างเดียวแล้วก็
เดทมันก็แบบถ้าผู้ชายแบบคีบตะเกียบใช่
มั้ยคะแล้วก็เอาตะเกียบคีบลูกชิ้นแล้วก็
ลูกชิ้นเนี่ยคีบไม่ได้กระเด็นใส่หน้าครู
ฟ้าก็ไม่โอเคผู้ชายเ้าก็รู้สึกไม่โอเคครู
ฟ้าก็แบบโอก็อาจจะรู้สึกแบบเค้าน่าจะอาย
นิดหน่อยใช่มยคืออาหารมันกินยากอ่ะค่ะนัก
เรียนอย่าสั่งก็เป็นการเดทที่สนุกดีนะคะ
แต่ถ้าผู้ชายเป็นคนสนุกๆก็อาจจะโอเคก็ได้
นะอันนี้ก็เป็นไอเดียให้นะคะนักเรียนก็
ไม่รู้นะเอออ่ะต่อไปนะคะอาหารที่มันต้อง
ใช้มือในการหยิบแล้วก็แทะอ่ะใช
คืออย่า
เชซี่โครงหมูซี่โครงหมอคือเมนูเนี้ยซี่
โครงหมูซี่โครงหมูเนี่ยมันใช้มีดก็ได้นะ
คะนักเรียนใช้
มีดใช้ซ่อมแต่มันยากมากที่สุดอันนี้มือ
นี้ใช่มยครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะเป็นมือคือนัก
เรียนไม่รู้นักเรียนมือไหนถือมือไหนนะคะ
มือซ้ายเอ่อมือซ้ายถือถือซ่อม
เนาะมือขวามือขวาถือมีดถือมีอ่ามือขวาถือ
มีดมือซ้ายถือซ้อมนักเรียนคะเราจะเอาซ้อม
เนี่ยกดลงไปบนซี่โครงหมูเอามีดหั่นเนี่ย
มันยากมากนะคะมันอาจจะ
กระเด็นซี่โครงหมูบินได้หรือเปล่า
เอ้าแล้วถ้าแบบนั้นคนที่เราเดทด้วยเค้าก็
จะตกใจเค้าก็อาจจะไม่เอาอะไรมากแต่เรา
เนี่ยแหละค่ะค่ะเราเนี่ยจะอายมากๆมันก็จะ
ไม่มีการเดทครั้งที่ 2 ไงมว่าเราอาย
อ่ะผู้หญิงแย่มากเลยนะคะแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าใช้
มือกินอืคือมันใช้มือกินไม่ผิดนะคะนัก
เรียนคุณหญิงคิดว่าซี่โครงหมูหรือว่าปีก
ไก่เนี่ยพวกปีกไก่น่องไก่แบบเนี้ยใช้มือ
กินเนี่ยมันโอเคแต่แค่ในการเราไปเดทครั้ง
แรกค่ะแล้วเราใช้มือหยิบหยิบซี่โครงหมูมา
แล้วก็
แทะมันดูไม่สวยมยคะนัก
เรียนมันไม่สวยหรอกค่ะมันแยกใช่ค่ะมันดู
ไม่สวยแบบว่าไม่ใช่ว่าเรากินแล้วมันไม่
สวยนะคะแต่มันคือการเดทครั้งแรกนะคะเรา
ต้องจำไว้เสมอนี่คือการเดทครั้งแรกปากก็
เลอะหมูอาจจะติดอยู่ในฟันอะไรแบบ
เนี้ยแล้วอีกอย่างนึงอ่ะเวลาเราแทะขึ้นมา
ผู้ชายอีกคนนึงอ่ะเขาอาจจะไม่ได้คิดกับก็
ได้ค่ะว่ามันไม่สวยแต่เขาแค่แบบฟ้ากินแบบ
นี้หรอมันมันน่าตกใจนะคะบางครั้งอ่ะเค้า
ไม่ใช่เพื่อนเราไงกินแบบที่รู้จัก
เราใช่ค่ะกินแบบนี้นะคะอืใช่มันอาจจะเป็น
อะไรที่กินยากไงกินยากใช่มไก่ด้วห้ะไก่
ด้วยใช่ค่ะไก่ด้วยเหมือนกันมันกินยากอ่ะ
เออคือถึงแม้ว่าจะใช้มีดมีดเอ่อมีดกับ
ส้อมก็ยากใช้มือมันก็แบบถ้าเราคือปกติ
แล้วอ่ะถ้าเราไม่ได้เป็นเพื่อนกันเป็นพ่อ
เป็นแม่เนี่ยเราก็ไม่อยากจะใช้มือเมนู
อาหารแบบเนี้ยเราก็ไม่สั่งอยู่แล้วมยไป
กินข้าวกับกับคนที่เราไม่ได้สนิทมากๆอ่ะ
นะคะใช่จรครูฟ้าก็ถึงไม่ได้ไปเดทครูฟ้าก็
ไม่ใช้มือข้างนอกนะก็รู้สึกว่าปากมันก็
เลอะมือเลอะนะคะใช่เสื้อเลอะเออมันเลอะ
อ่ะค่ะนักเรียนนั่นแหละค่ะอ่ะต่อไปอันนี้
ก็ใช้มือเหมือนกันนะคะคือพวกอาหารทะเลคือ
อาหารทะเลเนี่ยใช้มือยังไม่เท่าไหร่เนาะ
หรือว่าแกะกุ้งแกะปูอย่างในรูปอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะแต่ว่าเราใช้มือกินเสร็จแล้วอ่ะค่ะนัก
เรียนกลิ่น
Forever แล้วผู้ชายก็มาจับมือเราไปดม
อื้อหือปูที่คุณกินเข้าไปปูอยู่ที่นี่
กุ้งอยู่ที่
นี่คือแบบว่ามันมันเลอะด้วยนะจริงๆเวลา
ครูฟ้าแกะกุ้งอ่ะครูฟ้าไปกินบุฟเฟ่ต์มัน
จะมีกุ้งให้แกะแกะกุ้งโอ้โหเลอะหมดเลยนะ
คะมือเสื้อ
แขนก็กลิ่นน่ะคือ 1 เขเหม็นหรือเปล่าเรา
ไม่รู้นะคะแต่ตัวเราเองเี่แบบอื้อหือ
อือหือกลิ่นกุ้งกลิ่นซีฟู้ดนะคะอันนี้ก็
เา้าก็บอกว่าอย่าเพิ่งสั่งในการเดทครั้ง
แรกนะคะก็คือเมนูที่ใช้มือ
หรือว่า
สลัดสลัดเนี่ยก็อย่าสั่งในเดชครั้งแรก
เหมือนกันอืสลัดทำไมอ่ะูหญิงมันก็ดู
Healthy นะคะแล้วก็กินง่ายทำไมใช่แต่เขา
บอกว่าถ้าเราผู้ชายพาเราไปร้านอาหารเนี่ย
แล้วเราสั่งแค่สลัดอย่างเดียวเนี่ยผู้ชาย
เนี่ยเขาจะคิดว่าร้านอาหารที่ครูฟ้าพามา
เอ่อที่เขาพาครูฟ้ามาเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
ครูฟ้าก็เลยสั่งสลัดเพราะว่าสลัดมันจะมี
อยู่ในทุกร้านอาหารแพงๆอ่ะเนาะในประเทศ
ไทยมันก็จะไม่ค่อยจะไม่ค่อยเป็นร้านอาหาร
ไทยสลัดเหมือนเป็นเหมือนเมนูเบสิคอ่ะ
เหมือนครูฟ้าไปกินข้าวที่ร้านอาหารไทย
แล้วครูฟ้าสั่งข้าวไข่เจียวอ่ะมีรูปให้
นักเรียนดูมั้ยคะข้าวไข่เจียวข้าวไข่
เจียวนะคะเปิดกันครูฟ้าเนี่ยเชอบกินข้าว
ไข่เจียวมากๆนะคะหรือว่านักเรียนอาจจะชอบ
กินสลัดมากๆเนี่ยข้าวไข่เจียวอืออืซึ่ง
มันเป็นเมนูที่ธรรมดาแบบธรรมดามากๆเบสิค
ไงถ้าครูฟ้าไปร้านอาหารแบบร้านอาหารไทยดี
ๆแพงๆแล้วครูฟ้าสั่งข้าวไข่เจียวผู้ชายก็
จะคิดว่าอ๋อครูฟ้าไม่ชอบร้านอาหารที่ผมพา
มาไม่ชอบเมนูอะไรเลยอันเนี้ยเขาก็เลยบอก
ว่าห้ามเราสั่งสลัดแล้วก็สลัดเนี่ยมัน
เป็นผักสีเขียวใช่มั้ยคะค่ะผักสีเขียว
เนี่ยเวลาเรากินเนี่ยเราอาจจะต้องเช็คฟัน
เราบ่อยๆไงมันมันดูไม่ดีมากๆนะคะนักเรียน
เรามีแครอทอยู่ที่ฟันบรอกโคลี่อยู่ที่ฟัน
อย่างเงี้ยติดอย่างเงี้ยค่ะเก็เลยบอกว่า
อย่าสั่งนะคะสลัดอืได้ค่ะอันนี้ก็
กระเทียมนักเรียนใช่คือไม่ใช่กระเทียม
อย่างเดียวนะมันอาจจะเป็นอาหารที่มีกลิ่น
น่ะมีกลิ่นคือกระเทียมเนี่ยมันมีกลิ่นนะ
คะมันอาจจะยากสำหรับเราเราอาจจะรู้สึกไม่
สบายใจในการพูดเพราะว่าเรากินกระเทียม
เข้าไปแล้วใช่มั้ยคะเราอาจจะคิดว่าเอ๊ะ
ปากเรามีกลิ่นหรือเปล่าใช่มยชัวหึกิน
กระเทียมอ่ะเหม็นนะคะชัวๆเหม็นใช่ค่ะหรือ
ว่าหัวหอมใช่มั้ยหัวหอม
เนี่ยอ่ะอันนี้ไม่ใช่หอมนะอันนี้กระเทียม
นะคะหัวหอมมันจะเป็นสีส้มๆหน่อย
อืหัวหอมก็จะกลมๆใช่มั้ยคะเวลาที่เราหั่น
แล้วแบบน้ำตาไหลนน่ะหัวหอมอย่างเงี้ยมี
กลิ่นเนี่ยนะเออนี่ๆไงเนี่ยหัวหอมเนี่ยนะ
หัวหอมเนี่ยนะคะอันนี้ก็มีกลิ่นมันทำให้
เราเนี่ยเวลาที่เราจะพูดจะคุยเราอาจจะรู้
สึกแบบเอเอ๊ะมันไม่ค่อยโอเคก็อย่าสั่งนะ
คะอาหารที่มีกลิ่นอือเหม็นนะเหม็นอ่ะต่อ
ไปค่ะส้มตำโหคนไทยเห็นก็คือ
แบบอยากกินส้มตำแต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยไม่ใช่
หมายถึงส้มตำนะคะก็คือส้มตำเนี่ยมันเผ็ด
มันเผ็ดใช่ไหมมันมีพริกเนี่ยพริกนะคะมี
พริกเนี่ยเผ็ดในในนี้เนี่ยก็หมายถึงว่า
เราอยในการเดดครั้งแรกอ่ะค่ะอย่าเพิ่ง
สั่งอาหารที่มันเผ็ดมากๆ
อืเพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยอะไรนะคะครูฟ้าทำไม
อ่ะก็ดีแล้วนี่กินอาหารเผ็ดอร่อยนะคะครู
ฟ้านะคะเวลาที่มันเผ็ดมากๆน้ำมูกไหล
เหงื่อออกคิ้วที่ครูฟ้าเขียนมาคิ้วหลุด
มาสคาร่าบ๊ายบายขี้มูกไหลเข้าปากสวยเหรอ
คะไม่สวยค่ะไม่สวยแล้วแบบบางคนเค้าเห็น
แล้วแบบหรือว่าผู้ชายก็ได้นะเป็นตัวเราก็
ได้เราเห็นแล้วอื้อหือเรากินไม่ได้แล้ว
อ่ะมันมีน้ำมูกแล้วก็ไหลบางคนเห็นแล้วกิน
กินข้าวไม่ได้ไงมันแล้วแต่คนไงเอออันนี้
คือมันเผ็ดไงคะพออาหารที่มันเผ็ดมากๆ
เนี่ยมันอาจจะทำให้เราเนี่ยเหงื่อออกใช่ม
เหงื่อไหลเราก็เช็ดเช็ดเช็ดแบบเนี้ยหรือ
ว่าน้ำมูกใช่มบางคนกินเผ็ดมากๆแล้วมันน้ำ
มูกไหลอืจริงๆเป็นอาหารที่เหม็นด้วยนะถ้า
ส้มตำเนี่ยเหม็นด้วยนะคะใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
อร่อยใช่นั่นแหละใช่ค่ะแต่อาจจะไม่ใช่ส้ม
ต่ำอะไรก็อาจจะเป็นอาหารอย่างอื่นที่มีรส
เผ็ดอย่างหมาล่าอย่างเงี้ยฮอตพอตหมาล่า
ที่เผ็ดมากๆต้มยำกุ้งที่เผ็ดมากๆนะคะ
เพราะว่าลองดูด้วยนะถ้าเราเป็นคนที่กิน
เผ็ดเก่งอืแล้วไม่น้ำมูกไหลไม่เหงื่อไหล
ก็ก็อาจจะโอเคนะคะอือือๆๆใช่ค่ะอ่ะต่อไป
ค่ะอันนี้เป็นสิ่งที่ครูฟ้าคิดเป็นอย่าง
แรกเลยว่าจะไม่ไม่สั่งเมนูเหล่านี้หรือ
ไม่ไปกินเมนูพวกนี้ตอนการเดทครั้งแรกทำไม
อ่ะผู้
หญิงอันนี้มันคืออาหารที่เราต้องใช้คำ
ใหญ่ๆในการกินน่ะค่ะนักเรียนคิดดูสิคะ
เนี่ยเรากินแฮมเบอร์เกอร์แฮมเบอร์เกอร์
ไม่ผิดนะคะเซฟแฮมเบอร์เกอร์เซฟ
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์นะคะแต่เวลาที่เราจะกิน
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ดูสิคะเขาต้องอ้าปากเอาเอา
เอาสีเขียวแล้วกัน
อ้าปากกว้างขนาดเนี้ย
คือ 1 มันดูมันดูไม่โอเคมั้ยผู้หญิงก็ไม่
รู้นะคะแต่การที่เราต้องอ้าากว้างขนาด
เนี้ยมันดูแบบคนที่เห็นก็อาจจะตกใจนิด
หน่อยแล้วก็ได้
นะมันก็ไม่โอเคนะนักเรียนใช่แล้วกัดเสร็จ
แล้วต้องอ้าปากกว้างใช่มั้ยแล้วก็กัดแล้ว
ก็แบบซอส
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์หรือว่าแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ก็หลับ
ไทางเนี้ยเพราะคนไทยบางครั้งเรากิน
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ไม่ไม่ได้รู้เทคนิคในการจับ
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ไงอือๆใช่มแฮมเบอร์เกอร์
เนี่ยเป็นอาหารที่คำใหญ่นะคะต้องกินด้วย
คำใหญ่คือใช้มือไม่น่าเกลียดเท่าไหร่นะ
โอเคใช่มยเพราะแค่ใช้มือจับอย่างเดียวนะ
คะแต่ไม่ใช่แค่แฮมเบอร์เกอร์นะครู
ฟ้าซูชิซาชิอันนี้เค้าเรียกอะไรเนี่ยโ
ซูชิอือันนี้ก็คำใหญ่นะคะ
ไม่ได้หรอมันอร่อยโอ้โหอร่อยใช่ค่ะเก็บ
ไว้ก่อนเดทที่ 2 ได้อะไรที่เรากินในเดท
ครั้งแรกไม่ได้เนี่ยเราไปกินในเดดครั้ง
ที่ 2 ได้นะคะถ้าเป็นเมนูที่นักเรียนชอบ
แต่ซูชิเนี่ยมันก็คำใหญ่ค่ะเราเห็นมยคน
นี้เค้าก็ต้องอ้า
ปากอ้าปากกว้างมากๆคือการอ้าปากกว้างใน
การกินอาหารมันก็มันก็ไม่ค่อยโอเคอยู่
แล้วในทุกการไปกินข้าวกับใครก็ตามอเนาะ
ซึ่งมันอาจจะต้องแบบ
อเค้าก็รู้มยว่าว่าเราอ้าปากกว้างถ้าเรา
มีมือแล้วก็ครีบ
ซูชิ
เอ้าครูฟ้ามันมีซูชิบางคำที่มันใหญ่มากนะ
คะที่มันกินยากมากหรือว่าบางครั้งมันต้อง
กัดอย่างเงี้ยการกัดโดยอย่าง
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์อย่างเงี้ยบางทีเรากัดแล้ว
เราแล้วก็ผักก็ติดออกมาเรากัดผักไม่ขาด
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะมันก็เลยเป็นอใช่ยากนะคะไม่
ได้นะอาหารคำใหญ่อ่ะ
ผลไม้ผลไม้ก็มีหรอคะอะไรอ่ะมีแตงโมเเนี่ย
เป็นตัวอย่างได้เลยแตงโมเเนี่ยถึงแม้จะ
ชอบมากแค่ไหนไปเดทครั้งแรกอย่าสั่งแตงโม
ทำไม
อ่ะแตงโมมันมีเม็ดนี่ไงคะ
เราจะต้องกินเม็ดเข้าไปหรือเราจะ
ขาเดชครั้งแรกผู้ชายกำลังกินข้าวอยู่ขุด
ฟ้ากิน
แตงโมผู้ชายเนี่ยก็นั่ง
ดื่มเอ้าผู้หญิงเม็ดแตงโมออกมาผู้ชายเอ่อ
ฟ้าที่บ้านปลูกแตงโมอันนี้เทคนิคปลูกแตง
โมเหรอครับแล้วก็คายแมดแตงโมไง
ใช่คือการคายเนี่ยมันอาจจะมีทิชชู่อ่ะมัน
ใช้ทิชชู่ได้นะคะในการคายแต่นี่มันคือเดท
ครั้งแรกไงมันจะรู้สึกแบบเราจะรู้เราจะ
คิดมากๆอยู่แล้วเพราะมันคือเดทครั้งแรก
ใช่ไหมยคะเราอยากให้เค้าเนี่ยชอบเรามันก็
เลยแบบเราอาจจะรู้สึกไม่ค่อยโอเคเองก็
อย่าสั่งนะคะแตงโมแล้วก็เครื่องดื่มโค้ก
เปปซี่สปส
แฟนต้ามิอะไรนะแรนด้าไม่ใช่รนดถูกแล้วเออ
มิแรนด้าใช่ไหมแฟนต้าโค้กเนี่ยอย่าสั่งนะ
คะเราเรียกว่าน้ำอัดลมน้ำที่มันมีแก๊ส
เนี่ยออก็โอเคิครูหญิงทำไมล่ะไม่ใช่แค่
น้ำอัดลมอย่างเดียวนะโซดาด้วยอะไรที่เป็น
น้ำโซดาไม่ได้ค่ะโดยเฉพาะถ้าเราเป็นคนที่
ดื่มโค้กเสร็จ
ถ้าเราเป็นคนที่เรอง่ายๆอน้ำอัดลมหรือว่า
พวกโซดาทั้งหลายเนี่ยนะคะมันมีแก๊สใช่มย
คะถ้าเราดื่มไปแล้วแล้วเราแบบกำลังคุย
อยู่ค่ะใช่ค่ะอึอย่างเงี้ยมันมันก็ไม่ดี
ใช่มแต่ถ้าเราแบบครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเขาไม่
เรอก็สั่งได้ครูพัเป็นคนที่ดื่มน้ำเปปซี่
น้ำโค้กสไปรแล้วก็ไม่เลอนะคะนักเรียนอ
โอเคแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
เรอดื่มให้มันเรอแล้วดื่มแล้วมันจะเรอ
ซึ่งมันคงไม่ดีใช่มั้ยคะมันแบบมันไม่ใช่
สิ่งที่ดีในการกินอาหารอยู่แล้วว่าเรากิน
อาหารแล้วเราเรอมนต์โต๊ะอาหารเนี่ยมันไม่
โอเคแล้วยิ่งเป็นเดทครั้งแรกก็อย่าสั่งนะ
คะสั่งน้ำส้มผู้หญิงสวยต้องดื่มน้ำส้มนะ
คะเนี่ยแะค่ะก็เป็นอาหารที่เขาบอกว่าอย่า
สั่งนะถ้าเราจะจะไปเดทครั้งแรกเนาะแต่ถ้า
เราเดทครั้งแรกแล้วคุยกันแล้วรู้สึกเอ้อ
โอเคมีเดทครั้งที่ 2 ู้หญิงคิดว่าสั่งได้
แล้วล่ะเพราะว่าเขาก็รู้จักแล้วรู้จักเรา
แล้วใช่มั้ยคะเห็นมั้ยไม่มีชาบูไม่มี
บุฟเฟ่ต์กินได้นะคะกินเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ดีมาก
ค่ะงั้นครูพระจะเลือกไปบุฟเฟ่ต์นะคะหมู
กระทะ
ชาบูแล้วก็กินได้ค่ะแล้วก็กินนะคะครูฟ้า
จะไปกินหรือจะไปเดท
คะกินก่อนครูฟ้าจะไปกินใช่มเพราะฉะนั้น
ครูฟ้าก็เลยไม่สนใจนะคะการเดทนะคะโอเคค่ะ
นี่แหละค่ะนักเรียนส่วนวีีดีโอนี้คิดว่า
เราไปก่อนเนาะเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้านะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ